with President Donald Trump removed from
yet another GOP Primary ballot this time
in the state of Maine we turned to one
of his competitors for reaction here to
weigh in live from the campaign Trail in
Iowa Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
Governor you just heard this news like
we did what's your
reaction well the idea that one
bureaucrat and an executive position can
simply unilaterally disqualify someone
from office that turns on it head every
notion of constitutional due process
that this country's Always abided by for
over 200 years uh it opens up Pandora's
Box can you have a republican Secretary
of State uh disqualify Biden from the
ballot because he's let in 8 million
people illegally a massive Invasion
including uh from enemies of our country
uh places like Iran China Middle East
have poured in with his knowledge and
Ascent basically uh so it really op
opens up Pandora's Box I don't think
that this ultimately will be legally
sustained uh by the US Supreme Court but
I do think that this is going to be a
constant throughout the election year
where there's going to be different
parts of these legal cases uh that are
going to be front and center uh I think
that we win uh when we hold Biden
accountable and talk about the issues
that matter to the American people so I
think the Democrats they want the
election to be about uh all these other
issues they do not want to face
accountability for their failed policies
what do you think the GOP should do and
what should the presidential candidates
like yourself do about
this well Jason one of the reasons I'm
running is because the midterm election
showed uh while Republicans failed
throughout most of the country in
Florida we won the biggest victory in
the history of the state for Republican
running for governor uh I think that a
guy like me as the nominee will be able
to keep the focus on Biden keep the
focus on the Democrats failures but then
more importantly after you win the
election start holding these people
accountable who have weaponized the
legal system to go after their political
enemies and that starts with day one
firing somebody like Jack Smith that
goes to dealing with people who are
violating constitutional rights at the
state and local go government area
Republicans have turned a blind eye to
abuses of power for far too long we need
to actually do something about it in
Florida we've actually done things we've
held people accountable and we've
drained the swamp in a major way we need
that in the United
States yeah I know you did that as
Governor getting rid of some of these
District Attorneys who were not not
willing to uphold the law uh Governor I
got to get your reaction to the other
top story you know we're just over two
weeks from that Iowa caucus uh Governor
Nikki Haley was asked about the cause of
the Civil War last night in New
Hampshire but her response had a glaring
Omission watch this what was the cause
of the United States stes Civil War well
don't come with an easy question or
anything I mean I think the cause of the
Civil War was basically how government
was going to run the freedoms and what
people could and couldn't do what do you
think the cause of the Civil War was I'm
not running for president I I I I I I
wanted to see your a good thing on the
cause of the Civil
War I mean I think it always comes down
to the role of government and what the
rights of the people are thank you and
in in the year 2023 it's astonishing to
me that you answer that question without
mentioning the word slavery what do you
want me to say about slavery no um uh
you answered my
question I mean that that was governor
that was not a difficult question they
may think that that was planted by
somebody but that's a pretty easy answer
for not a Hardball
question well it was a massive word
salad I still don't understand what she
was trying to say with that why she
would have gone down that road I don't
know look we're Republicans the the
Republican party was founded to oppose
slavery and its expansion and the reason
slavery got abolished in the United
States was because of the Republican
party uh and the election of Abraham
Lincoln uh and what happened in the
ensuing years and so I'm glad that the
role the Republican Party played uh in
Exterminating slavery from the United
States and that uh made us more in line
with the values that the country was
founded on that we all entitled to
god-given rights and we should be
treated equally under the but I do think
what it showed is uh she getting
scrutiny now has not held up well uh I
think she says things when she gets off
script she tends to make big mistakes
the media has really given her a free
pass for the last six weeks uh trying to
pump her up but I think the more and
more voters see that it's one thing to
read off a teleprompter it's one thing
to read talking points but you going to
be able to actually speak from a
position of of conviction and you either
understand the foundations of America or
you don't I have a firm understanding
that our rights come from God not from
the government and the purpose of
government is to protect the rights we
already possess and so everything I do
is seen through the prism of our
nation's founding
principles yeah if you don't understand
and can't utter the word slavery in why
the Civil War was fought what would why
why South Carolina was one of the states
that uh this brought this up as such an
issue way back in the day uh then you're
really missing a point here uh very last
question very quickly earlier in the
show we talked about teachers in
teachers unions you've actually done
something in Florida that's different
than what's going on in the rest of the
country how are we going to deal with
these teachers unions hold on on our
kids well one they are partisan
organizations now they're trying to use
our schools to impose a left-wing agenda
that's totally unacceptable what we did
in Florida is we said no automatic
deduction of union dues so if someone
wants to join they can write a check and
hand it over what that's done is that's
caused fewer people to want to join so
down in Miami Dade County massive Urban
School District massive teacher Union
historically very powerful they failed
to get the requisite 60% so they are now
going to be desertified uh that is going
to put more power in the hands of
parents it's going to be good for
students and here's the thing Jason I
don't need the the unions to to do
things for Education I've done billions
of dollars and pay increases for
teachers I'm happy to support our
teachers but we don't want the Union's
political agenda polluting our
schools yeah Governor Ronda Sanz I wish
I had more time but we got to run
Governor thank you for joining us
tonight on the ingr mangle hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else